au conseil de sécurité de l'onu russes
et ukrainiens se font face
le représentant de l'ukraine laisse
éclater sa colère les cerveaux
et oui
l art des footeux le secrétaire général
des nations unies semblent abattus de
serre de mount isa
neige
présente pour
l'humanité brink york troops back to
watch depuis le début de l' attaque
russe contre l'ukraine les réunions
d'urgence se multiplient our souls à van
der leyen annonce le gel des avoirs
russes dans l'union européenne et
l'exclusion des banques russes du marché
financier européen
pour le chef de la diplomatie européenne
le continent vit ses heures les plus
sombres depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale c'est bord l annonce des
sanctions de l'ue contre la russie les
plus dures jamais prises les traits
tirés de celui qui n'a pas dormi de la
nuit le président volodymyr zelensky
tente de rassurer les ukrainiens en leur
promettant la victoire
il appelle à l'unité des européens et
leur demande de monter une coalition
anti poutine emmanuel macron lui exprime
la solidarité de la france avec
l'ukraine et annonce agir avec ses
alliés pour que cesse la guerre et
pourtant vladimir poutine a déjà averti
cette nuit qu il répliquera à tous ceux
qui interférerait avec l'opération russe
moscou qui affirme ne viser que des
cibles militaires peut compter sur ses
alliés pékin notamment qui affirment que
le mot invasion est employé à tort par
les occidentaux